tagashi keeps teasing us with nobunaga's
ability hope he shows it in these next
two chapters right now this is the Soul
Thing giving me hope that Nobunaga won't
just die immediately because I didn't
know if tagashi would kill him without
giving us something and it is just
something and contrary to popular belief
we actually do know a bit about
nobunaka's ability first off he
definitely has one because shall knock
referenced it in chapter 104.
specifically he said that he and
nobunaga's abilities can be easily
replaced as opposed to shizuku and
poconotus so if anyone was expecting
anything complicated intricate or just
particularly special about nobunaga's
abilities look you might be disappointed
because chances are he just has a very
basic enhancerhatsu taken to a very high
level very much like what gon did with
his abilities which I would describe as
heightened basic and also UV again
actually over gains probably a much
better example because he was a troop
member who didn't have what we would
typically classify as a hatsu these days
just lots and lots of punching and then
Big Bangs so I would imagine that
nobunagara is just a more precise
version of move again which I think
makes sense because both of them were
part of the Phantom troop attack Squad
before uvergine was killed now nobunagra
is still part of the squad and novegin
isn't because he's dead for anyone who's
forgotten right now the most we know
about Nobunaga is that he has a four
meter end range which is directly
correlated to the reach of his blade and
friend introduced Kyson fans out there
you can kind of equate it to a simple
domain where if anyone enters the radius
of nobunagazen then they get instantly
cut up which is why having him stuck in
a Close Quarters room is still pretty
decent because I would imagine the
proper counter to Nobunaga is a ranged
ability but this is still problematic
because let's say sure he gets attacked
he uses whatever funky sword hatsu he
has maybe he even kills a handful of
Hayley dude Bros great but what next now
they know exactly what nobunaga's
ability is and he's lost his last
advantage in this conflict the Haley
family then just send in one of the like
20 other someones with a counter ability
and things get real bad real quick
Nobunaga attacking the wall is
definitely a nod to his encounter with
gone and kilowatt and in the York New
City Arc so this is something I didn't
notice at first but this whole situation
is very much like a reverse York New
City when Nobunaga had captured gone in
kilowatt he trapped them in a room with
himself guarding the doorway so in that
case Nobunaga was acting as the landmine
doorway nenability so what did gone and
kilowatt do well they exited through the
walls instead which is the exact
opposite of what's Happening Here here
Nobunaga was forbidden from entering the
room due to the land mine ability so he
used what I'm now going to refer to as
the gone stratagem and entered the room
through the walls instead and this is
why I really want to go back to York new
city in detail once the inevitable
Hiatus kicks him once more because when
it comes to the troop tagashi has a very
clear idea of what he wants oh and
another thing I didn't pick up on
immediately was Nobunaga talking about
teleportation as if he's experienced a
similar power before and he absolutely
has it's the most forgotten about
crawlow ability but he does have or at
least he did have a teleportation hatsu
stolen by skill Hunter it was used in
chapter 106 to teleport Nobunaga away
from hisoka and defuse is the incoming
battle that nobunaka wanted to start and
when you put all of this stuff together
you can see how Nobunaga landed on the
right answer here it's because of sheer
experience Nobunaga has experienced
similar powers and similar situations
before and then he just went Wham that's
the answer so his hypothesis was much
more on the mark than what Phoenix's
experiences taught him I've never had a
character grow on me as fast as Henry
dudes a boss completely agreed it's very
interesting to see how times change
isn't it Henry was introduced towards
the end of the before times and in fact
he was the very last face we saw before
Hunter Hunter went on its longest Hiatus
to date so we were left lingering on
this man for three years he talked a
pretty big game and I'm happy to report
that he definitely lived up to that
three-year Cliffhanger that he left us
on and I think the community is in
pretty shared agreement about this for
example some of the comments I read were
let me find these instead of Hunter
Hunter the series is now Henry Henry oh
and also if Henry's balls get any more
massive they might sink the entire ship
which is why if this guy dies now I am
going to be gutted even with the Phantom
troop flashback Henry has been the
narrative hero of this batch of chapters
taking command and making stuff happen
finding hisoka hunting the Haley and
gaining himself a brand new troop best
friend it really does feel like Henry is
the protagonist of this batch so please
don't die although speaking of I think
Nobunaga will be the first member of the
troop to die on the black whale tagashi
has given him so many highlights and
singled out moments that I think it's a
Tell-Tale sign that he's going out first
this is perhaps correct if this was any
other story yes I would be close to 100
sure that Nobunaga is going to die
imminently because he's just become too
damn likable and in my opinion right now
he would be by far the most hard-hitting
troop death the reason why I can't 100
buy into that though is because tagashi
often ignores or even deliberately
subverts narrative tropes so that you
can almost never predict what's going to
happen with that said right now his
situation is kind of like what happened
when hisoka walked into Heaven's Arena
to fight crawler no banana Naga has
willingly stumbled into a battlefield
chosen by his enemy his enemy has access
to an entire Suite of nen abilities and
Nobunaga himself as far as we know
relies mostly on a single type of power
the slicy slice and look we saw how well
that situation turned out for hisoka
pretty well actually he revived himself
from death and became a God but I don't
think the same thing is gonna happen
with Nobunaga I've got this very very
real fear but I did make a Nobunaga
death toll to see how all of you were
feeling about this with a whopping over
50 saying yes yes he is going to die now
to be fair I didn't ask if nobunaka will
die right here and now so a lot of that
could be a more future focused yes but
just under 20 said no and a quarter of
you were simply confused by your own
existence thus selecting the cross-eyed
nobunagar option when do you think we'll
get more information on Sheila alright
this this is what got me most about not
continuing the troop flashback because
including Sheila in that story ah was a
stroke of Genius it threw everything I
thought I knew about the troop and
karapika's past just completely out of
whack and in the end we were left on
this like Precious seesaw of non-answers
because Sheila very well could have
committed a big old betrayal and
essentially be responsible for the
formation of the Phantom troop but at
the same time she could also be a
completely innocent party who got caught
up in this exceptionally bloodthirsty
web of Revenge but I really want to know
what happened to her because Sheila as
far as we know found the curta remains
and then continued on to achieve her
dream of becoming a hunter but we've met
a lot of Hunters by now and Sheila this
is not one of them with the exception of
the very Fringe theory that Sheila is
parastan which is something that I've
never really seen Fitz cover on the
channel and remember I am the guy who
really thought that illumi as hisoka was
plausible so that should tell you a bit
about the Sheila paristan idea I don't
know that maybe I should just do it for
fun because stupid theories are so good
they're my favorite theories I mean it's
not the worst idea I've ever heard it's
far from the best though the spiders are
toast warm buttery toast have you know
that spiders on warm buttery toast is an
Australian Deli casino and you've got me
feeling quite hungry right now no
seriously where did the other two guys
they sent go did they even go to the
same room as before is the user able to
switch the destination of the
teleportation on the fly or is this some
other ability alright so this commenter
is asking about the two Mafia guys that
feitan basically pushed through the door
at sword point and I don't blame people
for not getting this whole segment
tagashi is is sometimes a bit weird with
paneling and like portraying the passage
of time but these two guys did end up in
the same room as Henry and obanaga did
they were likely killed as Henry notes
with very fresh Bloods all over the
floor but Henry also suspects that they
were interrogated whether that's true or
not I don't really know I personally
think they probably weren't interrogated
because there wasn't a lot of time
whilst the Haley family already knew
that the troop were coming after them so
they took away the bodies and set a new
trap in regards to time though I think
some people were also confused by how
quickly Nobunaga appeared behind Henry
and here I solely blame tagashi's
paneling because I can see how it gives
the impression that the Phantom troops
started following the transmitter signal
and then having this whole conversation
before Nobunaga chose to go as well
because we cut to the radar then show a
wide shot of the general public area of
tier 3 and then back to the troop which
gives the illusion of movement that the
troop have covered that distance and are
now in the public area but in reality
they're still right in front of the
doorway I personally think this could
have been made much clearer because
evidently it did confuse a whole ton of
people but essentially Henry vanished
like so
and then the troops spoke for less than
a minute before Nobunaga went yeah I'm
gonna make a friend and then went in
will you cover every chapter that gets
released from this point on that's the
idea in fact that was always the idea
however a slight problem did occur with
chapter 396 and I'm still getting
questions about that right now but I got
sick the week that chapter came out like
real sick and by the time I was well
enough to record again well look it was
time to talk about 397 so I just had to
skip one hoping not to do that again but
due to my unhealthy fascination with
fictional Hunters I will absolutely be
talking about every new chapter because
these reviews really help my
understanding of the series as well
sometimes Hunter Hunter look we all know
it can be a bit dense so it's always
helpful to sit down and just take some
time to work things out I don't really
understand what the goal of Hunter
Hunter is just to explore the unknown
and get sidetracked 50 times yeah it's
actually a really good question what is
the point of Hunter Hunter because
there's no real discernible end goal
anymore no farther to find no pirate
king no sister to cure and at this this
stage I think the point of Hunter Hunter
is just to follow the living breathing
world that tagashi has created and
bringing these characters that we've
already met to satisfying conclusions at
this stage Hunter Hunter doesn't really
need a point though not like a typical
Shonen Point anyway because we lost
track of that point literally decades
ago when the Chimera Antarctic began the
point of the series now is an
exploration of just whatever the hell
tagashi wants to bring into existence
because he's built up enough trust as a
Storyteller that his fans are pretty
much willing to follow him wherever he
so desires to go and there are very few
authors who can pull something like that
off I wish we knew if Togashi is
continuing or not like I love Hunter
Hunter best anime manga ever but I kinda
get disappointed if we get into a Hiatus
again well wish no longer because we do
know as mentioned in the chapter review
tagashi's assistant has confirmed that
at least 30 more chapters have been
written in fact they were written four
years ago to clarify that does not mean
storyboarded or even fully scripted but
there is a broad outline and an intent
to make them happen with that said I
would expect short Hiatus to be
occurring quite soon because when
chapter 400 comes out that will Mark 10
new chapters which is the traditional
batch release number we do know for a
fact that we're continuing Beyond 400
though because work has already begun on
chapters
401-404 in fact we know that Togashi
finished the storyboarding for chapter
400 in Late July because that's when he
posted the image of karapika and maybe
that actually gives us a really good
timeline expectation that chapter was
drafted about five months before it's
actually going to be published and to be
fair that's because they were waiting
for at least 10 chapters to be close to
complete before commencing publishing
but we could find ourselves in a
situation when we do have big
multi-month breaks between batches maybe
even up to five or six months which I'm
pretty fine with because just about
anything beats waiting another three
years